e
e e
[Music]
good evening um I'm calling the finance
committee uh for November 25th 2024 to
order uh we have several resolutions
beginning with temporary resolution
129 a resolution to authorize the city
of Lancaster auditor patrici Nettles to
request an advance of funds from the
Fairfield County Treasurer James bonson
for the city's apportionment of property
tax settlement for
2025 coming from the finance committee
and uh auditor Nettles please uh yes
this is an annual piece of legislation
um in order for um the for me to request
from the county to get uh the cash
advances uh for our settlements I have
to get your permission via leg
legislation this is just an annual piece
yeah we do this on an annual basis um
you're requesting three readings uh
would you be interested in two readings
that's yes I'm fine with two readings
and I could earlier I can get it up to
them so we don't miss their deadline
which is in January but their deadline
is uh in sometime in January right and
the idea is try to clear the docket as
much because as you all recall January
we have a ton of legislation and if we
can clean some of this up I'd like to do
that any objections to that we'll do two
readings thank you temporary resolution
number 130 a resolution to authorize and
then an now certificate for the
Community Development block grant fund
2073 chip home program fund
2083 and for the healthy homes Grant
2026 year ended
2024 a project expenditures coming from
the economic development committee
councilman who yes Chasin will be here
to share about it good evening Mr
President and Council um I have met with
auditor Nettles and this will be a new
standing annual piece for the funds kep
at HUD so it's for the projects that are
um currently ongoing so they can get
paid in
2025 any
questions and we're looking for three
readings y
okay um you it need to go three readings
it can be if we can get it uh two
readings that would be good that way she
has it so she starts out the
2025 budget year she would already have
then and now already for any expends
before our first meeting in January
perfect any objections to that I hear
none and
um and your second will be Christina mhm
okay thank
you now we have temporary resolution 131
a resolution to authorize the service
safety director to enter into a contract
for the construction of the zann Ali
sewer replacement project coming from
water water pollution control uh
councilman Wayne yes thank you Mr
chairman uh this project is actually
located uh just out the door here across
the street uh the alley between City
Hall and the police station uh 300 ft of
sanary sewer that is in desperate need
of replacement and I'll invite Steven
well set to come up and way
more all right thank you Michael uh
Council good evening to the rest of you
um so yeah this project as noted we got
about 300t of Sanu sewer in very bad
shape we're going to do a replacement of
the project uh we did advertise it uh
did have the bid opening uh two Fridays
ago on the 15th we only had one bidder
but they came in um only 2% over
Engineers estimate so we were thankful
for that and uh it's Rock River
Construction local contractor and um
obviously at this point um we're the the
bid was reviewed looks like everything's
okay to go so uh we'll be ready to uh
sign contracts once we get this
legislation approved keep moving forward
with
it happy to answer any questions if
anybody
has yeah uh requesting two readings so
we can get this uh passed and signed by
the end of the year and uh Mr Al will be
my second perfect thank
you temporary resolution 132 a
resolution to authorize the service
safety director to enter into an
engineering agreement for the 2025 sewer
Rehabilitation project again coming from
water water pollution control councilman
Wing yes thank you Mr chairman uh the
the
um I lost my train of thought there uh
basically all the sewers in the city are
they have the sneak process where they
use a uh Clos circuit television they
examine the oldest sewers and see which
ones need uh replaced each year and
that's what this piece is
for yeah correct uh annually we do the
CCTV work and we have found some sewers
that we feel are in um a poor enough
condition that some um very short-term
Rehabilitation is needed uh we have a
combined sewer on Madison Avenue between
6 and mberry another combined sewer on
East Main Street near the intersection
with sted Avenue a uh some sanitary
sewers in the stonate meadow subdivision
which is fog drive that area those are
very pretty relatively new uh sewers but
we have a lot of infiltration concerns
there unfortunately that's adding a lot
of flow to the pump station that Mike
Nixon and his Department have down there
uh so this project would include some
include some grouting there to um
obviously reduce the storm water that's
getting into our sanitary sewer uh and
then on the storm sewer side we have a
storm sewer on East 6th Avenue between
high and maple that we're looking to get
rehabbed and we may add in a storm sewer
on um 8th Avenue uh that runs through
the vacant field there that you to the
old Drive-In behind Todd's Mountain View
um that's going to be pending some
findings that are going to happen here
in the next month or two um but uh again
yeah this legislation would is just for
the engineering uh agreement to design
the rehab project needed for those
sewers thank you any questions
all right uh Council WIA will be my
second on this one and I'll also be
requesting two readings so we can get
this started at the start very good
everybody okay with uh
that next is temporary resolution 133 a
resolution to authorize the service
safety director to advertise for bids
and enter into a contract for the
construction and inspection of the 2025
Street Improvement program hyphen Paving
project coming from public works and
councilman T this is just what it says
uh authorizing to advertise for bids do
you have anything to say for the uh
Paving
carry I don't have anything to add I was
G to say I would offer engineer Kurt
Shan to come up if he would like to
speak good evening so uh this is our
annual U program to to our Paving
program for the 3 mil Levy money I'll
just go quickly through how we select
our streets I think it's an important
reminder every year um there are things
that we look at are traffic so the
higher
traffic you know the quicker it's going
to get attention the condition the
payment condition we have that surveyed
um we consult that out every 3 or four
years they'll come in and do an
assessment on every street every Public
Road in the C City and they give us a
score on those
roads um we have to coordinate with our
utilities to make sure we're not going
to pave a road that's going to get tore
up right away or at least within five
six seven years and that can be
difficult and sometimes we have to pass
on areas that we would otherwise like to
get paved funding so all of these
streets that we're going to talk about
or or that for this project are local
streets that are not eligible for
federal funding are collectors and our
arterials have other pots of money that
we can use to pave those so we try not
to do any of our local streets on this
program um then we get together with uh
the engineers office staff and some of
our L do staff and we get together and
we talk about what streets we're going
to pay the following year something that
we did last year and we're going to do
this year uh we are trying to work our
maintenance uh projects our micros
surfacing in with our
resurfacing projects to get finish out
entire
neighborhoods the thing about the micr
surfacing is it's just a a thin little
layer that buys more time um so we think
it's important to get into those
neighborhoods because you might get a
street that gets micros surfaced and the
the next street over is falling apart
and I wonder why didn't my street get
paved that one didn't look too bad and
it it got paid it's a different
treatment it's it's less than what we're
we're doing here so um that's kind of
the rundown I have a list of the streets
here I can read those off it's kind of a
long list and and I'm not sure if you
have those in front of you or not but
they're on the uh west side of town over
around um kind of Harrison and West West
Fifth uh we're also doing grath which
was one of the streets that we did not
do this year even though it was in the
bid package
because uh the water line needed
replaced we found that out after we got
started um West 8th West
7th
mury Smith Avenue just to name a few so
I'll take any questions if you have
any okay thank
you any other okay counc or
any uh Mr
lenberg um I've asked the other ones if
you have any interest in suspending the
third reading or or you want to go the
three I mean getting the year started we
could um yeah we could just because it's
just uh go for bids so yeah we could do
that we could suspend any objections
around the table thank
you we want to make sure he's plenty
busy right mhm doesn't have anything
else to
do um next is temporary resolution
number 134 a resolution to amend
appropriate appropriation budgets and to
subsequently amend the certificate of
other sources and Appropriations with
the county auditor uh finance committee
and um I defer to auditor Nettles to
explain what you're doing yes this is an
annual piece as well um this is where um
we're going through my staff that went
through and looked at everybody's
expense 2024 expense budgets and
bringing them in line with their cash
onand or Revenue as of December 31st so
we needed to go through in um lower
expense budgets to meet their cash so
that's all this
is and you need that done by the end of
the year obviously yes correct I need I
need it in two readings please we're
look at at two readings and uh
councilman ALS would you be the second
please thank you
that is it for the resolutions moving on
to the
ordinances
um temporary ordinance
52-24 an ordinance to Grant to Grant to
South Central Power Company its
successors and assigns a franchise for
the right to acquire construct maintain
and operate in the streets thorough
fares alleys Bridges and public places
the
the I'm sorry places of city of Langer
and its successors lines for the
transmission and distribution of
electric energy to the city of lanaster
and the inhabitants thereof for light
heat power and other purposes and for
the transmission of the same within
thorough or
across uh said city of Lancaster and to
declare an emergency coming from the law
committee and councilman crates yes
thank you uh to comply with state law
south central power must have an
agreement to provide services within the
city the current agreement has expired
and this legislation is to approve a new
one law director Hall did you want to
provide any anything
additional I just wanted to say
essentially we're giving um South
Central Power here the exact same rights
and privileges that we've given to a or
um Ohio power as they're called um this
the terms of this agreement are the same
in terms of length which is 25 years for
both and then in terms of renewal which
is onee successive renewals thereafter
so the thought was level the playing
field and keep everybody on the same
terms and conditions and um you know
address this again in the future if
necessary thanks thank
you and then Mr wolfinger is my second
I'll be happy too two readings and I'm
assuming you're doing the two readings
because the contract has expired and you
like get put together by the end of the
year correct yes sir thank you thank you
I assume there's no other
questions uh temporary ordinance
53-24 an ordinance to De two Parcels of
city property 053
8611 and 0
53583 0000 containing
3.09 plus or minus acres of land from
the city to the city uh to be
Consolidated into one parcel and that's
also coming from the law committee and
and uh councilman cres yes thank you um
is there anyone in the administration or
law director Hall that would like
director H yes thank you ma'am sorry um
so you all probably remember um back in
June you passed legislation to purchase
the 1 acre parcel next to uh Engine
House one on East Main Street with a
thought of future development no I'm
sorry that's Engine House 3 um on East
Main Street um but with the thought of
future development potentially on the
front of both Parcels um and then on the
back the fire department had already
planned and had uh designs started for a
maintenance and repair facility that
would span across the back of both Lots
in order to get those designs um
approved through the city actually um
the it has to be one parcel the building
can't be sitting on two different
parcels and so the assistant city
engineer already went ahead and got um
got the entirety of all of the real
property resurveyed and the county
auditor's office just let us know this
week that all they need us to do is file
a new deed that uh puts those two
Parcels together so that they can go
ahead and give it one parcel number and
that will solve all of the problems
moving forward so that's the goal
tonight and I ask for suspension because
you're really not divesting the city of
any property rights you're just
basically moving it from two different
parcel numbers down into one parcel
number thank
[Music]
you um Mr bisj is my second thank you
any questions regarding total
suspension thank
you moving on to Temporary ordinance
54-25 an ordinance to authorize the
service safety director to enter into a
lease contract with the Fairfield County
Commissioners for the second floor of
the City Annex Building 123 East
Chestnut Street for juvenile court
services also I know this is coming from
the administrative Services committee uh
councilman lenberg this this is a
walk-on correct councilman
yes yeah as the safety service director
please uh talk to this one yes thank you
and my apology for having this as a
walk-in piece uh I found out um just
recently that we have a lease agreement
that is expiring um for our 121 East
Chestnut we rent the third floor to
Fairfield County Juvenile Court um and I
missed that this was expiring this year
um so I've been working with law
director uh Hall on putting together a
new lease agreement um and then she
reminded me politely that I needed uh
legislation to be able to execute set
agreement um because our agreement
expires at the end of this year um I
would respect I asked to walk it in so
that we could at least get two readings
on this um so that we can get Council
approval and then I can get it to the
county so that they can also get it to
the Commissioners and have that read
before the end of December so that we
can enter into this
agreement a question
go ahead
um I know we've done this a couple I've
been sitting here to do it a couple
different times I was curious on the the
past two times that we've done those
lease agreements there's
been an increase in the rent but this
has no increase over the previous one so
I was curious on why we're doing that
this time so from I looked in the
records to try and find where the
amounts were actually derived from and I
didn't have a good answer and again
we're on a short timeline um the rent
Revenue goes back into helping maintain
the building
so based on what we've spent in that
building over the last few years I did
not see a need to increase it um over
the next three years if Council wishes
that I do that I'm more than happy to
I'm again this has not gone to the
county yet um I just based on what we've
spent in
maintenance and I couldn't find where
the rental rates were actually derived
from like an appraisal or anything um so
I just thought it was best to keep it
flat until I can maybe get an appraisal
in the
future on what we should be
leasing um
I I appreciate the answer I don't know
if that makes any sense in terms of you
can look at the previous ones and figure
out what the percentage increase was for
the lease so I mean everything and what
we're dealing with with C cost increased
whether it's our property they're
dealing with the same thing so again I
was
just concerned or confused on like we've
like I said was just a standard 3% or 4%
increase and there isn't one in this so
I'm not sure why we would leave it flat
for for the next three years um and then
as far as I don't explain to me or maybe
the law director can explain to me the
days intent to discontinue or if it
continues it just continues after the
three years at the same
price I does that make sense what I
asked I guess or did I ask a question
yeah you're talking about the holdover
provision I believe um and I did add
language to this because I thought the
holdover provision was not necessarily
um Ironclad so the holdover provision
says that they can continue to rent the
building at a rate that is higher
monthly every 30 days um but then it's a
month-to-month tency at that point so I
did ask language to change that because
you know while I don't think that the
county would do it um we need to have a
right to terminate the tency um when we
need to terminate the tency and so I did
put in a 30 days notice provision to do
that so that they couldn't hold over
indefinitely does that make sense yeah I
yeah I was again curious because we I
know we're moving
some some people out of that building
what's the future for that building and
oh we still have plenty of people in the
building yeah and then the same time I
think we just did some legislation to
add a bathroom for yes whatever dollar
amount so correct that's where we could
recoup some of our costs on the
bathroom was my thought so so I might be
able to help you if I can dig into my
archives I have spreadsheets and things
that I did when I was
Treasure uh square footage analysis of
that type of thing rent for all this uh
I know we got two readings on the books
you'd probably need to get this done by
the end of the year since the lease has
matured um let me dig that out council's
pleasure and share it with everybody
that would be super helpful thank you
and maybe that might answer those
questions I can't remember back that far
but I do have something somewhere
believe me I know yeah it was just a
good question very good question usually
those continuations are some kind of
change right okay thank you counil
luberg I know this this was sent out to
everybody last last minute today I don't
have a copy of it in front of me so that
was I yeah you're right copies printed
apparently but um we're not going to do
anything today right we'll get some
information make a uh I guess I'm
supposed to be your second that's what I
saw okay I I just got one I printed off
off the computer so I'm willing to do
the second I will get information for
the law director what I can find in
Tom's files now I hopefully I have it on
the somewhere on a Excel spreadsheet
somewhere I hope and it's news you made
enough of them yeah I know I know uh
sorry to put you I'll just apologize
because I'm chair of the committee a
problem for that yeah um any other
questions
to as we're digging into things anybody
else want to add to the list to dig
into
okay thank
you and excuse
me and that is concludes the resolutions
or the ordinances I'm sorry um other
discussion items departmental updates do
we have any updates from the city
the
newly just a brief update for Council
you guys have been dealing with this for
two years um over the last two weeks
Lieutenant Lieutenant Kon um our
administrative Lieutenant has done a
phenomenal job meeting with Robertson
Construction and getting a phasing
outline done for the HVAC project at the
police department uh it does look like I
finally have some good news that um over
the course of December and January they
should have the majority of the heating
um the the majority of the heating
project done as long as well as the
cealing project and by Springtime before
Springtime before the the weather warms
up they will have the actual cooling
portion done there were no delays and no
long lead times for The Chiller or air
handler units which uh we were kind of
crossing our fingers for so extremely
good news that whole project should be
completed by well before the summer so
just wanted to get that update you guys
have been very supportive with that
project so I'm happy to report
that that's
all
questions from
Council thank you
Chief any other departmental
departmental
updates I hear none uh tonight meeting
prep will be uh by President Porter yeah
we have no uh special presentation uh by
departments this evening and therefore
uh we will be following the agenda as
written aside from the walk-on
legislation thank you any questions of
uh president
P thank
you moving on to um other items for
finance
excuse me first of all I wanted to
mention per uh auditor nettles's uh
request and through the service safety
director we're going to request uh
waving uh third reading on temporary
ordinance says 45 46 7 uh 48 49 50 and
51-24 um we had the first reading we're
running into potential time elements
I'll let you reader um yeah this is if
if if we could get those ordinance
suspended and passed this time this
gives all of the Departments ample time
to complete their employee status change
forms get them in um and and be able to
go through that and get them into the
office so we can then manually check
every single one of them U if Council
wants to have it go through readings
which is fine but it gives then it's
giving a short window for the
Department's like three days to get all
their stuff um into my office rather
than giving them a good two weeks to be
able to work on it and per perhaps next
year you and the service St director can
maybe plan a hint for the three readings
and yes well I mean I what was different
this year than it has been in the past
nothing except it it's it's like I hate
to say like it's hard for the
departments on reacting in the holiday
for them to get them so we're we're at a
critical mass of trying to say we need
this we're missing this one it's it's
you're looking at a window to get
450 um status change forms in in a small
amount of time and make sure you have
every single one of them um before we
move forward and and start for the new
year so it's just it's it's it's the
purpose of three readings as you know
and I'm not I'm not lecturing but it's
to give the public ample time to know
what's going on in relation to
operations of the city and I truly
appreciate the administrative confines
that go with that though um so in you
know I I'm not going to personally
object to to going to two readings
however next year we should go three
right we agree and that's why I
suggested we move that back and another
Factor the otter homeless
now you might explain that no we're in
the midst of uh moving up to the third
floor of City Hall so tomorrow the
movers are coming in and um it'll be
entertaining to get us our entire office
up to the third floor
so thank you any objections what were
those numbers
again the whole last all of these 45
through 51 thank you the rest of the the
numbers um if no questions good comments
I'm sorry member things that I mean if
we're doing the same thing and I just
you know I just see changing it I just
think because I I mean I kind of still
have some questions on some of the
employees and things
and I just know on on anything that's
well I appreciate that we uh get with
her or I mean you don't want to bring it
up on the council floor or if you're the
questions no I'm not I'm just going to
you know there's still questions I have
with the budget there's still things and
I think that needs to all be done at the
same time and I agree and that'll be
um well I guess you won't have time for
that was no on
that I appreciate
that other
objections any strong
feelings that was well no I mean you
know it's I mean he can always ask for
suspension and we'll go from there right
right okay appreciate it thank you can
we do a blanket suspension request or do
we need to go through all seven of them
and or all six of
them yeah you can do a blanket request
for all of them just need to be sure
that we read all of them off
still sorry sorry it's okay it's okay
we're not making anybody happy are we
you have to read them
all thank you um now i' like to turn the
uh program program the meeting if you
will uh to Mayor McDaniel
uh to discuss uh temporary resolution
11-24 um and he's prepared to discuss
current updates we have now certainly
thank you chairman wolfinger um this is
in regards to the budget
um
11-24 uh as you know we started the
budget process earlier this year than we
have in the past the budget is
legislation is currently on the table
and I'm going to recommend that we
continue to hold it on the table until
our next meeting uh this should allow
you time to review it as well as any one
from the public that wants to review the
budget it's out there for them to look
at uh bring any questions forward to us
and or the department heads and get
answers that you might have uh I'm
hoping to address a few of those uh
questions you may have right now and uh
I handed out a highlight sheet of some
things I think were important and I
wanted to draw your attention to that
are differences from uh previous budgets
uh you may know that we've merged human
resources in into the service Safety
Director's office um as well as adding a
facilities manager to that office based
on our discussion the last council
meeting uh even with those added
positions uh the savings by merging the
Departments together is about
$51,900 uh I listed the facility manager
uh recommended
salary um we save money by
um human resources and ssd's office
working together and sharing resources
and admin assistant various other things
that they can share as well as uh
assistance with uh our safety director
our service director is our human
resource manager for the City by Revised
Code so it makes sense that these two
departments work together uh hiring
firing discipline all that really runs
through the service safety director so
Human Resources makes a lot of sense to
be working Direct with her um in
addition we've done some other um
merging
consolidation uh We've combined planning
zoning building and Community
Development into one Department uh we
talked here at Council as to why we
would do that again we're sharing
resources reducing overhead and saving
taxpayer money um Pete Vil uh our
current zoning inspector scheduled to
retire and as uh stated on Council floor
at this podium him uh when he retired uh
when he was going to retire that we
would not replace him currently we have
no plans to replace him his uh
replacement already on staff and has
been on staff for approximately a year
now uh so he should be well trained and
ready to go um there's a savings
there uh Community Development salaries
uh have been decreased through attrition
from 545,000 down to
$358,000 uh the general fund
contribution for community service
has been decreased from 150 down to
95,000 uh my goal actually was to get
that down to 75,000 have we discussed
before but um we were unable to get it
there based on some commitments we've
already we already have um we'll look at
adjusting that going
forward uh the general fund proposed
budget is uh down
$278,000 plus from last year uh some of
the reasons for this is uh we were able
to move uh some of our expenses to the
police and fire levies that were
approved by the voters um I am actually
going to move some additional uh general
fund expenses to police and fire Levy
and bring in a starred version for you
to see uh at the next meeting it will
change will not change the figures at
all it'll just change the fund the money
is coming
from so uh you will see that expect to
see that coming your way soon um police
and fire Staffing is currently 84
firefighters and 79 uh police officers I
should say approved Staffing because I
don't think either department is fully
staffed yet but we're headed in positive
direction on that uh hopefully soon and
hopefully we can keep that Staffing for
a period of time as we know it's it's
tough but uh we'll work forward uh look
for making that happen over time um the
police budget uh you may notice is
higher um because of our air
conditioning um the chief spoke about
air conditioning heating uh project that
we have to complete that's been
on on our plate for some time I think 22
2022 is when this started been using a
temporary air conditioning unit just to
get by in the summer it's been very
difficult even finding uh a contractor
and getting someone to actually handle
that project has been difficult so uh
the good news from the chief tonight
looks like we're headed towards uh
completion sometime
soon uh the police department uh budget
does include an additional com Tech uh
Chief Snyder and uh director Woody and I
spoke about uh the Staffing in the radio
room and
uh it is very difficult currently with
the staff we have to get our um comex
appropriate breaks and lunchtimes by uh
adding an additional compact this will
allow that to happen on a more regular
basis uh something that they deserve I
will tell you having worked at the
police department for 30 years uh many
of those contacts uh would forgo their
lunch foro their breaks stay in the
Radio Room do the job uh not complaining
not asking much but this is something
that we should do and and if we would
have had the money would have done a
long time ago so this will allow Better
Staffing in the Radio Room uh when when
it's
needed so uh also including in the fire
budget plans for a new Firehouse
construction
planning um and also the construction of
the previously approved Maintenance
building at Firehouse number
three so when I say construction
planning we're not ready yet to finance
a new Firehouse but ready to plan for
building a new
Firehouse uh the tree commission budget
includes one additional employee uh as
many of you know uh councilman alss
knows firsthand because he's attended
most of the uh tree commission meetings
they have a lot on their plate and they
haven't had a l a lot of help and this
is an effort to improve that
situation uh it should be noted that
they asked for help last year and they
were denied um due to budget constraints
but uh I think we're in a position where
we can fund this position and help um
the tree commission to get its work
done uh the budget also includes
facility Investments at City Hall and
the City Hall Annex uh painting and
repairing of the interior of City Hall
windows and lighting we are getting a
$13,000 Grant uh for the lighting and
windows uh we are doing flooring on the
main floor of uh the annex excuse me um
if you were in the annex to that floor
has not been replaced in probably 50
years and it's in bad condition it's
actually kind of embarrassing to look at
but uh um we're going to try to update
that there's currently no facilities B
facilities in the
basement um we're also uh putting money
in the budget to add uh that to the
Annex Building to allow our employees to
have a place to currently right now they
have to go upstairs and that there's a
very small bathroom in the engineer area
but there's a public bathroom out in the
lobby um it's kind of inconvenient for
everyone this will be a good upgrade for
that
building uh should be noted that we we
the city occupy every area of the second
uh the main floor and the
basement
so all departments have seen increases
in their insurance cost salaries based
on collective bargaining Andor pending
legislation benefits inflationary costs
supplies equipment contracts
everything's up for everybody that's you
notice that in the budget
increase um improvements in the budget
um some of them you're going to see U
tornado siren equipment tornado siren
maintenance it Improvement ments um
$360,000 for City Hall improvements this
is the planning part of it as you know
we're looking at a approximately 5 to
5.5 million renovation of City Hall
something that hasn't been done in
really decades for the
exterior um we will keep you posted but
I think uh schoolly Caldwell is about
ready to give us some more information
hopefully very
soon and then
uh gas is putting additional security
fencing or an automa gate in place
that's in the budget as well as a water
plant Furnishing for the new water plant
there's certainly a lot more in the
budget than that but those are some of
the highlights I wanted to draw your
attention to uh Municipal Court is
adding a part-time armed security to the
front of the building there where the
when you come in the building they have
a a metal detector they've been using
unarmed temporary
staffing uh the judges both feel that
that's not adequate for their needs and
uh actually judge Fields has issued an
court order saying that he's going to
require armed security we're talking
part-time they have a pretty good plan
in place um he made that order effective
immediately uh so we will include those
figures in the 25 budget the court will
pay for that out of their special
projects
funding the next item I have is the uh
community reinvestment area agreement we
have with Google and Magna and our
school systems are involved in Mana
Clear Creek and laner City Schools uh
the law director has been working on
this for a period of time and we have
some um income tax sharing that is
required by the revised code as a result
of the community reinvestment act
benefits that the properties receive so
we are working on finalizing that that
you'll see also in the
budget uh Parks is budgeting for Improv
M ments um including seal coat at the
parking lot at Olive Dale this is shared
50/50 with the senior uh citizens um
group at olivedale senior citizens
whatever they call that particular
organization I'm not sure um we're
looking at replacing the pool heater at
olivedale uh Roofing which is also a
50-50 shared cost with the uh senior
group uh backflow preventer at Miller
pool and a tiki Pool slide uh I think
it's a renovation not a replace
uh sanitation budget reflects an
increase in Refuge hauling and this is
attributed to um serving the new
transfer station a different type of uh
I think the trucks are bigger and are
hauling more so it required a new
renegotiation of the contract which is
costing us additional hauling fees to
haul uh
refuges uh gas Transmissions costs are
up and they they're that is determined
by market forces and um we have been
advised that it's likely to be it's
being um
contested uh through the regulating
bodies and there's uh typically we're
told that price will drop will drop
again but in the short term we have to
pay the cost and we hope to save later
uh when they lower that cost
factor and then uh
lastly uh engineering added an office
manager to replace admin assistant as
you know Deb Julian is retiring uh storm
waterer will participate in covering
that salary but it's kind of a billable
hours how she will the new person would
track their hours based on how many
hours they have provide help to
engineering and how many hours they
provide to storm water so that's kind of
a highlight and I'm certainly open to
questions if if you have them about any
of these items and or anything else in
the budget C in in the uh Parks budget
um when we met with Steve
he mentioned specifically that they were
going to set aside
$75,000 for Bowers
Park he he has told me the same that
it's in the budget under his
improvements it's just not listed in
your comments but it $75,000 for bars
park is in the budget okay thank
you mayor on item 13 uh the pool heater
replacement at olivedale is that the
50/50 shared also
I'm sorry say that again the olive Dale
pool heater is that a 50-50 share also
no the it is not that the pool is our
responsibility
um he could probably ask for help with
that but it's a um not only to olale
senior citizens use that pool but also
the rec center um members use that pool
okay thank
you other questions
counil Miner I know you mentioned you
had some questions on the budget oh I'll
SK with an Ask later we'll just there's
just some things I need to go through
since we've gotten some things over the
you know past few days I just have
questions that's fine I didn't want to
excluded um thank you so I would just
say the reason we're leaving this on the
table is for you to be able to go back
and visit these things and ask
additional questions we hope that uh we
can have those questions answered for
for you to your satisfaction and be able
to vote on the budget at our next
meeting so thank
you and thank
you I would entertain a motion for
adjournment so
moved okay I need to do a roll call ALS
yes it's going to over Yes W finger yes
we are um done at
6:44 lanaster city council will convene
its regular meeting at
6:50 hi I'm Corey Clark with Fairfield
County Job and Family Services our
mission is to protect children and
elderly andour family stability and
promote self-reliance for a stronger
Community this month when you buy a car
truck or SUV from Buckeye Toyota or
Buckeye Honda their Buckeye cares
program will make a donation with every
vehicle they sell from all of us at
Fairfield County Job and Family Services
thank you Buckeye for your ongoing
support for local
[Music]
families the Frankie Smith Funeral Home
in cremator in Lancaster and the Johnson
Smith Funeral Home in Baltimore have a
long and wonderful history of serving
our community feel free to give us a
call at
0652 stop in and see us at either of our
two locations 405 North Columbus Street
in Lancaster and 207 South Main Street
in Baltimore respect for tradition
regard for change
[Music]
e
e e
ladies and gentlemen if you could stand
and join me in a moment of prayer God
grant us the serenity to accept the
things we cannot change the courage to
change the things that we can and
finally the wisdom to know the
difference
and now call the November
25th 2024 Lancaster City council meeting
to order please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance IED Al to the of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liy and justice for all
please call the r Mr ALS here Mr bisj
here Mrs CR here Mrs hoop here Mr
lenberg here Mr skover here miss Diner
here Mr Wing here and Mr wolfinger here
let the record reflect that nine members
of lanter city council are present at
today's meeting um since our last
meeting we had had a resignation
submitted to the first board by council
member um alers uh he had um he has
purchased a home outside of his Ward and
would no longer be eligible to serve
within that Ward we thank him for his
service and his time on Council and we
know that he will have uh another future
here with the city um and we will be uh
congratulating him on his service at a
later
date um we'll now move to the reading
and Disposal of the journal regular
meeting minutes dated November 4th
2024 Mr President i' like to make a
motion to receive and file the reports
of the city officials I'm sorry the
journal yes the journal file the journal
please second a motion to second
to I got you file the
journal all those in favor please say I
all those oppos same sign we'll now move
to the reports of City officials email
dated November 5th 2024 regarding
resignation letter by submitted by Mr
alers email dated November 5th 2024
notification of first war resignation of
Mr alers to the fairf board ofed uh
elections submitted by law director Hall
email dated November 5th 2024 regarding
notification on transfer new transfer
station opening submitted by
superintendent Shan fer email dated
November 6 2024 regarding Auditor Office
end ofe schedule update um submitted by
auditor Nettles uh email dated November
7th 2024 regarding income tax October
2024 revenue report submitted by Tax
Commissioner Amy Hamilton email
voicemail dated November 12th 2024
regarding the new transfer station
positive comments um provided from the
public uh submitted by superintendent
Shan fer multiple emails from City
Administration and council members dated
November 23rd 202 for regarding South
Water Treatment Plant Water
emergency Mr President i' like to make a
motion to receive and follow reports of
City officials second have a motion a
second to receive and file the reports
of City officials all those in favor
please signify by saying I I all those
oppose
same thank you uh we will now move on to
Communications series of emails dated
November 6 through November 15 2024
public records request regarding um tax
incentives or credits submitted by Ellen
Thomas of Business Insider in New York
and answered by law director Hall series
of emails between Jill tagman and
Council clerk Scott dated November 7th
2024 regarded larger scaled map of
purpos annexation paperwork series of
emails dated from November 6th through
November 24th between law director Hall
and Adam cely with Bricker grade in
regard of the Val talip Jed expansion
petition November 6 6 uh a letter dated
November 6 2024 the council clerk had
received notification from Ohio Division
of liquor control that V Nail and Spa
LLC doing business as V Nail and Spa has
filed for a liquor
license um November 18 2024 letter
received of notice of
to notice to legislative authorities in
regards to objections to renewal of a
retail law or liquor permit submitted by
Department of Commerce Division of
liquor
control Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and file the
communications second we have a motion
and second to receive and file the
communications all those in favor please
signify by saying I I all those oppose
same
sign we did jump the gun in finance
committee to say there would not be a
special presentation this evening at
this time I would like to ask the mayor
to address councel and community members
regarding the Water emergency that
occurred this past week thank you Mr
President yes um as we all
know about 300 p.m. today uh the boil
alert for lanter City uh water was
lifted I don't know how that got shut
off but my
apologies again the boil alert was
lifted at 3 p.m. but how did we get here
so um on on um Saturday uh director
Woody was contacted by our water
department advising her of uh
maintenance issues at the South Water
Treatment Plant these were unforeseen
unplanned um the issues were that uh
contamination was uh getting into our um
essentially where the water comes into
the plant it was getting into what is
essentially a filtration uh system and
levels that were essentially causing
our process to uh not work
appropriately so water department has
been working on this for quite some time
uh and they thought several times they
thought they had it
fixed
um and I I have to apologize because I
don't know exactly what a skid does but
the water enters the system and goes
through a skid
unit that captures
contaminants those contaminants uh
typically uh it takes three three months
or longer for a skid to become U full
and have to be
cleaned that was happening in about a
week and a half at $14,000 for each
cleaning of these skids and getting them
ready to go again um it was alarming so
experts were
consulted um contractors were consulted
uh our own water department people who
have significant experience had never
seen anything happening quite like this
and they really couldn't figure out why
um our department superintendent um came
up with a uh a thought he ran it by the
experts and it was that uh the well head
is down below the surface under
underwater it connects with a stainless
steel pipe and a coupling
that coupling over time had
separated allowing water to Cascade into
the well head causing contaminants to be
fed back into the system that shouldn't
be there Iron magnesium that type of
material
uh they then consulted the EPA about the
issue and the epaa gave advice and that
was advice was that that needed to be
fixed uh understanding there were no
uh readings of contamination but if you
fix your system by shutting it down that
is your where your potential
contamination will result from so any
disruption in the system whether it be
disruption in pressure or taking the
system offline requires an automatic
precautionary boil
alert it's precautionary because we
don't want contamination to get in the
system
so when the system goes out of service
we fire it back up for a short period of
time after
that we test the water to make sure it's
clear of any
contaminant and the EPA has a 24-hour
waiting period for that testing so we
test the water we were confident that it
was clear yesterday but that's not the
requirement the requirement is
independent testing has to be done away
from the city of Lancaster and verified
by the EPA and then they give us
clearance to put the system back in
service we don't believe at any time
there was any significant issues with
the quality of the water however
EPA policy procedures require this just
to make sure that the water that's going
into the system is quality water that we
can count on that the community is safe
to drink it and that that we would drink
it so part of it was a procedural issue
with EPA and we needed to fix this
problem
uh as far as anyone can
remember Lancaster's never had a
shutdown of the
system no one can remember one I've been
here 63 years I don't remember one if
anybody remembers one please let me know
you would enlight me on something that
means that we typically have good
quality drinking water going out out to
this community uh and uh the Water
Department does a very good job this is
a very unusual occurrence um stainless
steel is made to last the couplings are
made to last um the plant is 24 years
old TW approximately 24 years old that
should have been a 50-year pipe coming
out of that well head but the coupling
separated causing the problem and it
really had to be fixed and that's why we
ended up in the situation we were in
again if and I'm no water plant expert
but typically we can uh move from one
well to another without taking our
facility Offline that was not able to be
done in this particular situation and
the experts would have to explain that
in better detail than I could but um
they tried everything they could to keep
the plant online assuring Safe Drinking
Water was coming out we needed to fix
this problem the costs were
extraordinary but not only the cost
obviously we still had iron and
magnesium and other uh uh materials
infiltrating the water system
so on Saturday when that happened EPA
has a a kind of
a a template on information that you
release to the public and they're not
public officials elected officials like
we are sitting around this room they're
bureaucrats running the EPA and they
have their job to do and uh the press
release they that they agreed upon
understand this was went all the way
through uh from our
contact at the EPA to the state of Ohio
EPA director this is a big deal 42,000
people in this city uh drinking water
not available it's a big deal uh so they
they rant it up the flag pool we got a
PR press release out there I am not
happy with the press release the Way It
Was Written I believe that unanticipated
or emergency should have been in there
so the public would know that this was
not this was not plann maintenance this
was a unusual occurrence that we didn't
know was going to happen we could not
plan for we couldn't give advanced
notice because we didn't know ourselves
that we're going to take the plan
offline um I would have
been happier with a more detailed um
informative press release but also um in
addition to that uh when we put that
press release out we put it out via uh
TV radio print social media um we shared
it on City websites we shared it with
County um we shared it with uh all the
large U the hospital um Chamber of
Commerce um and many other organizations
throughout the city trying to get the
information out but the truth
is we have to do better than what we did
uh we have to and and we do have some
avenues that we we can pursue so that we
have better communication in emergency
situations regardless of whether it's
water or storms or flooding or any other
type of emergency and U that is
something that I promise we will and can
do um with that said currently we have a
system that are that anyone in the
community can sign up for on our website
to get alerts from the city uh our
website is uh www
c.
lancaster.oh do us at the bottom of that
page it talks about alerts and or what
uses a different word than alerts but
notify me notify me you go down you
enter information and notify me and you
can choose to be alerted from everything
from the main page to any other things
you might be interested legal notices
codes and Zoning Etc but more
specifically if you get notifications
from the main page you're going to get
every emergency notification the city
sends
out that's step I would like everybody
in the community to take right away but
in the meantime we are going to we're
going to solve our problem on better
communication and we do have I think we
know uh some um technology we can use uh
again this isn't there is no 100% way to
notify the public of any
emergency but uh we believe we can
notify everyone's cell phone in the
area uh of course you have to have the
cell phone with you you have to read it
but but it's a much better communication
tool than what we did what we did did
not get the information out to
everyone um it doesn't meet my
standard we have to do better but with
that said
uh you know you send information to the
media you hope they release it I was
told that people saw things on Channel 4
but didn't see it on channel 10 or
whatever it might
be that's one step we're still going to
do those steps we're going to still give
it to the radio TV print media social
media but then we're going to blast it
out on cell phones or whatever mechanism
we can to get it out there you know I
did have a caller today thought that we
should s
19-year-old teenagers to knock on
everybody's door that's a great idea but
it would been very tough it it was
getting dark and I think they would have
been knocking at 3:00 a.m. but the
thought of getting the notti out is
something that we have to do a better
job with so and I know that many of you
have received phone calls from your
constituents um those concerns are valid
we're going to do better so um I think
we do have again technology we believe
that we can use going forward this this
will not happen
again thank you Mr Mayor do we have any
questions or inquiries from Council
Members council member bisj uh thank you
Mr president uh Mr Mayor Madame SSD and
the water department first I just want
to say thank you for all your effort on
this uh I only have one question for you
is there anything that we on Council can
do to help you out with this effort
that's all well if we come forward with
any cost on uh this emergency notice
system I would hope you would support it
thank you council member lenberg uh
amber alerts that goes out to everybody
is that a technology not available to us
for technology is not available Amber
Alert is strictly missing child alert
and there's a huge criteria sometimes
you'll see that there's a missing child
and there's no Amber Alert it's because
even missing all missing children don't
qualify for an amber alert you have to
have significant amount of information
to justify the amber alert but with that
said we're talking about the same type
of Technology it would just be a
different a different name for it but
it's still going to reach cell phones in
our
community and it'll the way it'll be an
alert system the same way so it's a typ
it's similar to an amber
alert yeah that's excellent council
member Tiner I I will say at at
Children's we have a Chaz or something
and we get even water alerts from
communities I've never heard of I mean
you'll get them but that is one thing
anyway with being on the water committee
I was on that I was at that meeting
Friday it was just a regularly scheduled
meeting so the gentleman from the water
uh South Water Plant was there and he
said they had been working 24 hours a
day over time how long has this been
going on because for for us to have that
meeting I knew nothing about this so
Friday we had this meeting
Saturday this all started and we even
got a text from you saying well we'll
let it you know let people know like to
not today or tomorrow and I'm like
texting you going yeah sooner better
than later you know so how often how
long has this been going on though I
mean for this to be because he was
talking about filters and paying
overtime and they've been there they're
exhausted so is this was that part of
what happened over the
weekend well the short answer is yes
it's part of what happened but I I think
I was fairly clear that we did not
anticipate having to shut the plant down
nor did we anticipate a water boiler as
a result of that uh they've been working
on that problem the water plant both our
North plant and our South plant can
operate 24 hours a day 7 days a week 365
days a year typically without
interruption this was an unusual
occurrence and I think I explained it in
Fairly good detail I'd be happy to go
over it again if somebody well that's
fine but he he was pretty concerned on
Friday and and i' I'd even put in my my
text to you I've never seen him that
exhausted and that I mean he he did so
that's all true yeah so I I'm just
wondering um so how often is the water
test tested at the lab how often do they
T repeatedly multiple times a day every
day of the year uh in accordance with
EPA guidelines and they will shut you
down if you don't comply okay so last
night at well this morning at
12:43 talking about notifying people I
went on our website just the the
lanester city website so talking about
that really should have been that that
notice I know it's hard to get a hold of
everybody but that notice should have
been the first thing that popped up on
the website it wasn't the first thing
that popped up on the website in little
squares was Lancaster Council all in one
agenda then Thanksgiving day and then
you had to scroll and then it said yard
waste and then it said boiler advisory
so you know I think in the future I know
this is hard this is something that
happened you know unexpectedly but
probably the boiler alert should have
been the first thing that popped up on
the website absolutely and it's that's
already been fixed if you go to the web
page now I didn't know if you were aware
of it so you go across the top you'll
see in bold uh letters it says alert and
then it says boil alert canel Etc that
technology is available and absolutely
that needs to be corrected so question
I'm getting from people uh flush should
they be flushing the lines and changing
water fills
filters well the answer is yes and that
they should flush their lines I believe
I don't know that that was maybe there
was a second notice that was put on what
I would tell you is that uh at no time
do we believe our water was contaminated
but EPA recommendation is to flush your
lines and that gu those guidelines are
on our website under the water
department I would recommend that people
follow those guidelines if they feel
they need
to was that coun thank you um Mr Mayor
thank you for that update is there any
other council member who has any any
inquiry seeing none um Mr Mayor I know
that you were mentioning the technology
as a potential for getting to the cell
phones Fairfield County EMA has that
capability and will partner uh with the
community as needed absolutely we're
we're we're in contact with them and
we'll make sure again we might have
additional technology beyond that the
EMA is certainly a resource for us thank
you thank you we'll now move on to
petitions and
memorials oh there are no petitions or
memorials this
evening thank you clerk SC
we'll now move to permission of Voters
and taxpayers to address Council are
there any audience members here that uh
wishes to address city council this
evening we can correct that we'll remind
individuals that they need to sign the
sheet and provide their name and
address and um you are limited to three
minutes good evening president Porter
mayor uh council members and other
leaders of our community I appreciate
the opportunity to speak with you this
evening my name is Brian ever I reside
at 2011 South High Street here in city
limits and I wanted to just again talk
about pedestrian safety with respect to
our roads um I am aware of two crashes
involving pedestrians in the last week
um from speaking to some people that are
going to talk right after me I think
there may have been more um that I was
not aware of um I understand as we
discussed the budget that changes which
address the transportation needs of all
of our community members cost money and
cannot happen overnight uh the system we
currently have is car focused and
designed to move cars as quickly as
possible which doesn't uh lend itself
well to not only the safety of
pedestrians or Bic bicyclists or other
people in other modes of transportation
but doesn't lend itself well to a
community um that system is been in
place for pushing a 100 years so I know
this isn't going to happen overnight but
I would suggest that there are quick and
lowcost ways that we as a city can look
at making changes immediately as cheap
as paint with uh painting at
intersections that causes visual
narrowing of the street and typically
will psychologically induce drivers to
slow down um from there you have plastic
ballards that can be used for what's
known as daylighting at intersections or
where there are crosswalks
um preventing cars from parking
illegally past signs and preventing
pedestrians from having to go out into
the street to be able to see if it is
safe for them to proceed the remainder
of the way um also allowing cars to see
those pedestrians um granted 99% of them
don't know that Ohio law requires the
yield to pedestrians but it's a start um
and then from there things to slow down
pedest or I'm sorry cars that are
physical instead of paint whether those
are chicane or bump outs whether those
are raised crosswalks that show that the
priority is uh not only cars but that
pedestrians have equal access and equal
rights in those roads um that also act
as speed bumps to to slow cars um I
would ask that the city council and the
rest of the community uh leaders here
focus on um some type of progress even
if that progress is small because it
takes a step to start the journey thank
you thank you is there anyone else that
wishes to address council at this
time hello again uh pedestrian safety as
well my name is Levi baros I reside in
city of limits in
Lancaster um on Monday November 18th and
19th uh as well as Friday November 22nd
and Saturday the 23rd we've had
uh pedestrians hit on each of those days
uh my concern is the amount of
jaywalking today I witnessed a two adult
males cross Main Street from South Broad
Street
while
uh whoa while the people on Main Street
had the green light causing all of us to
come to a complete stop and the first
car swerving around the last guys that
took their time with no care for their
safety or if they care or if they cause
a crash so while the city is working on
pedestrian safety and continuing to work
on it making the city safer I in the
most respectful way to all the people
can start if you guys can start
enforcing laws that are being broken
like
jaywalking or not abiding by laws like
that my second concern is to both of our
courts in my eyes the lack of
accountability from some probation
officers I feel like the same thing goes
here with the lack of accountability
with Jay walking that I
see and it will continue to happen until
they be held
accountable uh some of the defendant on
probation catching new charges racking
up
warrants and they will not change
because I feel like linkster has such a
big problem with verism thank you for
your time guys thank you sir and can you
please sure be sure to give your address
and um sign in on the sheet
please are there any other individuals
here this evening that wish to to
address city
council greetings members of city
council my name is Tammy Beck I live at
1570 East Main Street law of 43 here in
the city limits I'm here today to
address address you all about the boil
alert that was issued on Saturday
November 23rd
2024 I got no notice directly from the
city regarding the boil alert the first
notice that I got was from the
children's ministry director at my
church they alerted me about 7:00 p.m.
on
Saturday supposedly the nose went out
sooner in the evening that caused a bit
of a panic within my mind and my
household my mother and I had to spend
extra money I really didn't have to get
drinking water in my house I didn't want
to risk any risk to any member of my
family getting sick especially me
expecting I'm very disappointed in the
city that the fact that the notice came
out so late in the evening and no one
not everyone is able to hear about
it if the city knew about it sooner this
notice should have been sent out sooner
than what it did plus the city needs to
understand that some people do not have
access to social media or the internet
the city should have something set
up similar to what laner city schools
has in place thank you thank you is
there any other individuals at this time
that wish to address Lancaster City city
council good evening my name is Tom
James I reside at 352 Mound Street here
in Lancaster I'm not going to pile on
with the communication for the boil
alert but this morning as I was at the Y
for my workout I was accosted by half a
dozen people that knew I had been on
Counsel before and that had something to
do with the U the Wastewater water
treatment and storm water and
environment engineering and I tried to
caution them on you don't want to jump
to conclusions but the wording could
have been a little bit better and I
really appreciate the comments and the
things that you're going to do to make
this communication much better but you
never want to underestimate the power of
networking because once I got the word
on Saturday night I was able to call at
least 12 of my members of in my
neighborhood and they in turn called
people and it's kind of like a geometric
progression where that that really made
a big difference but once again that
doesn't necessarily ensure that you're
going to reach everybody uh having been
close uh to all the people that work at
our our water treatment system they are
some really darn good people and they
know what they're doing and the skid you
mentioned uh mayor McDaniel um they're
bag filters and unfortunately once they
get completely plugged with iron you
can't get water in anymore now iron
itself is not a hazardous material but
it can cause Havoc with the plant and
trying to keep it running and they
really didn't have a choice at one point
in time you just had to finally shut it
down fix the collar and continue on from
there so my I have to praise your
efforts to do that and in that process
so that's all I have to say Thank
you Mr President I want to correct the
statement I made earlier to Becky's
question uh we had a uh correspondence
with the water plant manager and no
flushing is required the reason no
flushing is required is because the
samples were all negative both before
and after the incident so no flushing is
required you can flush if you'd like to
but no flushing is required thank you
mayor for that clarification is there
any other individual who'd like to
address city council this evening
seeing none we thank you uh for your
attendance at today's meeting uh we move
to the reports of standing committees
finance committee minut minutes dated
November 4th 2024 submitted by Mr wolfer
law committee agenda and minutes dated
November 5th 2024 submitted by Mrs cres
Safety Committee minutes dated November
1st 2024 submitted by Mr bjack finance
committee agenda dated November 2nd 2024
submitted by by Mr
wolfinger water water pollution agenda
and minutes dated November 24th
submitted by Mr Wing and finance
committee agenda dated November 22nd
2024 submitted by Mr W
finger Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to receive and file the reports
of standing committees second have a
motion and second to receive and file
the reports of standing committees all
those in favor sign signify by saying I
I all those oppos same sign reports of
special
committees there are no special
committee reports thank you public
hearings we have none on the agenda we
will now move to the reading of
resolutions we'll move to the third
reading of temporary resolution 11
14-24 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to enter into an
engineering agreement for various
construction Administration services for
the solids handling replacement project
water water pollution committee Mr Wing
and Miss steer council member Wing uh
thank you Mr President I'd like to make
a motion that Council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record uh
resolution temporarily number 11
14-24 second we have a motion in a
second to pass and gross and enter upon
the written record temporary resolution
11424 um any discussion council member
wng uh yes this is located at the water
pollution control facility on Lauren
Street uh will be funded by 1.2 million
Ohio EPA loan thank you any further
discussion hearing no none please call
the role Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs K
yes Mrs hoop yes Mrs Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes
and Mr wolfinger yes temporary
resolution
11424 passes 9 to0 temporary resolution
11524 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to adverti for
bids for the solids handling facility
replacement project water water
pollution committee Mr Wing and Mr ales
council member Wing thank you Mr
President I'd like to make a motion that
Council pass engross and enter upon the
written record uh resolution temporarily
numbered 11
15-24 second have a motion and second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
11524 discussion council member Wing yes
this pertains to the same project we uh
just discussed and um plan is to go out
to bid in January thank you any further
discussion hearing none please call a
roll Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs CR Mrs
hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes
Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes temporary resolution
11524 passes 9 to0 temporary resolution
11724 a resolution authorize the service
safety director to enter into a contract
with Fairfield healthc Care
Professionals Inc to provide
professional health care and wellness
services to city of Lancaster employees
and their dependents into declaring
emergency um administrative committee Mr
lenberg and Mr bisj council member
lenberg Mr President I'd like to make a
motion the council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record resolution
temporarily number
17-24 second we have a motion a second
to pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
11724 uh discussion council member
lenberg yes this has to do with a uh
contract that the city is entering into
with fa healthc Care
Professionals uh to augment uh Wellness
checks for city employees very similar a
contract that the county has and has
found to be very uh good for them and so
we're moving in that direction as well
thank you any further
discussion hearing none please call the
role Mr alss yes Mr bisj yes Mrs K yes
Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover
yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes Mr woler
yes temporary resolution 11724 passes 9
to0 temporary resolution
11824 a resolution to authorize the
service safety director to enter into a
contract with the
Renaissance yeah Renaissance Counseling
in in consultation to provide
professional mental health counseling
services to city of Lancaster employees
and their dependence and to declare an
emergency administrative committee Mr
lenberg and Mr wer council member
lenberg
uh thank you Mr President I'd like to
make a motion that Council pass engross
enter upon the written record resolution
temporarily number
18-24 second have a motion a second to
pass Andross and enter upon the written
record temporary resolution
11824 council member lenberg uh yes this
is similar to the previous resolution uh
just having to do with mental health
Counseling Services the city is entering
into a contract for thank you any
further
discussion hearing none please call the
rooll Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs KES yes
Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover
yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes temporary resolution
11824 passes 9
to0 now move to the second reading of
resolutions we have none we'll now move
on to the first reading of resolutions
with temporary resolution number one
29-24 a resolution to authorize the city
of Lancaster auditor Trisha Nettles to
request an advance of funds from the
Fairfield County Treasurer James bonson
for the city's appointment apportionment
of property tax settlements for 2025
this is finance committee Mr wolfinger
and Mr alss council member wolfinger yes
uh first of two readings please first of
two readings on temporary resolution
12924 temporary resolution
13024 a resolution authorized then
announced certificates for the Community
Development block grant
2073 chip home program fund 2083 and the
healthy homes Grant 2026 year end 2024
project expenditures Economic
Development Committee Miss hoops and Mrs
crates counc council member hoop yes
this is first of three readings thank
you first of three readings on temporary
resolution 130 24 temporary resolution
13124 a resolution authorize the service
safety director to enter into a contract
for the construction of the Zan alley
sewer replacement project water water
pollution committee Mr Wing and Mr ALS
council member Wing first of two
readings please first of two readings on
temporary resolution
13124 temporary resolution
13224 a resolution authorized the
service safety director to enter into an
engineering agreement for the 2025 sewer
Rehabilitation project water water
pollution committee Mr Wing and Miss
hener council member Wing this will be
the first of two readings please first
of two readings on temporary resolution
13224 temporary resolution
13324 a resolution authorized the
service safety director to advertise for
bids and enter into a contract for the
construction and inspection of the 2025
his street Improvement program Paving
project Public Works committee Miss
tener and Mr lenberg council member
Tiner Mr President I'd like to make a
motion that Council suspended rules and
wave the second and third reading of
temporary resolution 133 second we have
a motion and second to suspend the rules
and wave the second and third reading of
temporary resolution
133-20 um please call the r Mr ALS yes
Mr bjack yes Mrs C yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes M ten yes Mr
Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes motion to
suspend the rules in way the second and
third reading of temporary resolution
13324 passes 9 to Zer council member
Tina Mr President IID like to make a
motion the council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record temporary
resolution 133
second uh we have a motion and second to
pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary resolution
number 13324 council member Tiner any
discussion uh yes it's just so we can
get the project moving for next year for
the street Paving thank you any further
discussion hearing none please call the
RO Mr Al yes Mr bisj yes Mrs KES yes Mrs
hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes
Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes temporary resolution 13324
passes 9 to0 temporary resolution
13424 a resolution to amend a p or a
corporation bud budges and to sub
subsequently amend the certificate of
other sources and Appropriations with
the county auditor finance committee Mr
wolfinger Mr alss council member
wolfinger first of two readings first of
two readings on temporary resolution
13424 we will now move on to the reading
of ordinances there are no um third
readings of ordinances this evening we
will now move to Second reading with
temporary ordinance
4224 an ordinance providing the is for
the issuance and sale of notes in the
maximum principal amount of
$360,000 in
anticipation for the issuance of bonds
for the purpose of paying the cost of
the renovation of an existing building
for use by the city's Municipal Court
together with all necessary apperances
there to and declar an emergency finance
committee Mr wolfinger Mr ALS council
member wolfinger uh thank you Mr
President I would like to make a motion
that Council suspends it rules and waves
the third reading of uh temporary
ordinance temporary uh 42 days 24 second
we have a motion second to uh suspend
the rules and wave the third reading of
temporary ordinance
4224 any further discussion council
member wolfinger thank you this is an
annual piece that we will have as long
as we have debt outstanding uh that
dealt with the renov ation uh building
of Ed Road in in order for it to expand
several years
ago okay I think this was the Municipal
Court mun I'm sorry this was the
Municipal Court not Ed Ro I'm sorry cost
overun I will save that comment bring it
down because it's the next one down all
right any uh this is the uh the balance
of the loan will be paid down
$180,000 from 5 4 to 360 and renewed for
an additional year atted at the end of
2025 thank you so any further discussion
on the motion to suspend hearing none
please call the roll Mr ALS yes Mr bjack
yes Mrs CH yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg
yes Mr skover yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing
yes and Mr wolfinger yes motion to
suspend passes uh 9 to0 now move to um
council member wolfinger Mr President
I'd like to make a motion that Council
pass Andross and enter on the written
record uh temporary ordinance number
42-24 second have a motion second to
pass gross and enter upon the written
record temporary ordinance 4224 any
further discussion no thank you please
call the rooll Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes
Mrs CH yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes
Mr skover yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes
and Mr wolfinger yes motion to pass um
temporary ordinance 4224 passes 9 to Z
temporary ordinance
4324 an ordinance providing the issuance
and sale of Revenue notes in the
aggregate principal amount of
15,552
42 to pay cost of improving Ed Road
Memorial Drive in Michael's Way by
grading widening Paving curving and
improving Bridges and railroad crossings
relocating utilities and installing
sidewalks traffic signals and signs and
water sanitary sanitary and water water
lines and facilities together with all
necessary apperences there too and
declare an emergency finance committee
Mr wolfinger and Mr alses council member
wolfinger thank you Mr President I would
like to make the motion that Council
suspends rules and waves a third reading
on temporary or ordinance number
43-24 second a motion second to suspend
the rules in way the third reading of
temporary ordinance
4324 council member wolfinger again this
is the Ed Road renovation construction
project it was put on the book several
years ago and this is the annual pay
down and we'll have a few more years of
it going forward thank you any further
discussion on the motion to suspend
hearing none please call the role Mr ALS
yes Mr bisj yes Mrs K yes Mrs hoop yes
Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes M tener yes
Mr Wing yes and Mr
wol motion to suspend the rules and made
the third reading of temporary ordinance
4324 passes 9 to0 council member
wolfinger Mr President I'd like to make
a motion that Council pass and gross and
enter upon the written record temporary
ordinance number
43-24 second have motion second to pass
and gross and enter upon the written
record tempor ordinance 4324 council
member wolfinger any further discussion
no additional comments thank you please
call the rooll Mr ALS yes Mr bjack yes
Mrs CH yes Mrs hoop yes Mrs Mr lenberg
yes Mr skover yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing
yes and Mr wolfinger yes temporary
ordinance 4324 passes 9 to Z temporary
ordinance
4424 an ordinance providing the issuance
and sale of a revenue note in the
aggregate principal amount of
$221,950 to reimburse Flagstar Bank FSB
for the a draw on the letter of credit
in the connections with the cost of
improving Ed Road or moo drive and
Michael's Way by grading widening Paving
curving and improving Bridges and
railroad crossings relocating utilities
and installing sidewalks traffic signals
and signs and water sanitary and storm
water lines and facilities together with
all necessary apperances there too in
declaring emergency finance committee Mr
wolfinger and Mr alss council member
wolfinger Mr President I'd like to make
a motion that Council suspends rules and
waves a third reading of temporary
ordinance
44-24 second a motion a second to pass
uh suspend the rules and wave the second
or excuse me wave the third reading of
temporary ordinance
4424 any discussion council member
wolfinger pretty much the same annual
fece of legislation of renews for onee
additional note involving the Tiff
project on Ed Road thank you any further
discussion no sir hearing none please
call a rooll Mr ALS yes Mr bisack yes
Mrs CH yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes
Mr skover yes Miss tener yes Mr Wing yes
and Mr woler yes motion to suspend the
rules and made this the third reading of
temporary ordinance 4424 passes 9
to0 council member wolfinger Mr
President I would like to make a motion
to council pass and gross is interpon
the written
record temporary ordinance
44-24 second a motion second to pass and
gross enter upon the written record
temporary ordinance
4424 uh no discussion no more discussion
thank you please call the rooll Mr ALS
Mr bisj Mrs KES yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes M tener yes Mr
Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes temporary
ordinance 4 42 24 passes 9 to0 we now
move to Temporary ordinance
4524 in ordinance to establish the
benefits titles and compensation for the
information technology
administrator Office of the clerk of
court um employed by the city of
Lancaster Ohio commencing the first PID
period of 2025 and declare an emergency
administrative um committee Mr lenberg
and Mr bisj council member lenberg thank
you Mr President I'd like to make a
motion that Council suspend its rules
and wave the third reading of ordinance
temporarily
numbered
45-24 second we have a motion second to
P to suspend the rules and wave the
third reading of temporary ordinance
4524 discussion council member lenberg
uh yes Mr President this uh ordinance
and the next five ordinances are all
just yearly uh ordinances to establish
benefits and titles compensation for
various people and uh uh positions
within the city and uh we need to get
this on the books for the auditor uh
quickly so we're asking to suspend the
third reading thank you any further
discussion hearing none please call and
roll Mr ALS yes Mr Bish yes Mrs CH yes
Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skun yes
Miss tener no Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger
yes
motion to suspend the rules and wave the
third reading of temporary ordinance
4524 passes 8
to1 council member lenberg thank you Mr
President I'd like to make a motion that
Council pass and gross enter upon the
written record ordinance temporarily
number
4524 second have a motion second to pass
Andress enter upon the written record
temporary ordinance
4524 um any further discussion
none thank you please call the rooll Mr
ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs CH yes Mrs hoop
yes Mr lockberg yes Mr skover yes M
tener no Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger
yes temporary ordinance 4524 passes 8
to1 temporary ordinance
4624 an ordinance to establish the
benefits titles and compensation for
fairford County Municipal Court
management and professional Personnel
employed by the city of lancas Ohio for
the year 2025 and to declare an
emergency administrative committee Mr
lenberg and Mr wolfinger council member
lenberg thank you Mr President I'd like
to make a motion that Council suspend
its rules and wave the third reading of
ordinance temporarily numbered
46-24 second we have a motion in a
second to suspend the rules and wave the
third reading of temporary ordinance
4624 uh council member lenberg any
further discussion and none at this time
thank you um please call or rooll Mr ALS
yes Mr bisack yes Mrs CR yes Mrs hoop
yes Mr lber yes Mr skover yes Miss tener
nope Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger yes motion
to suspend the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary ordinance 4624
passes 8 to1 motion or excuse me uh
council member lenberg yes thank you Mr
President I'd like to make a motion
Council pass and gross and under upon
the written record ordinance temporarily
numbered
4624 second second we have an a motion
and a second to pass Andress enter upon
the written record temporary ordinance
4624 uh any further discussion n please
call the rle Mr Al yes Mr bisack yes Mrs
K yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover yes M tener no Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to pass uh an
engross and enter upon the written
record temporary ordinance for 624
passes 81 temporary ordinance
4724 an ordinance to establish benefits
titles and compensation for fful County
Municipal Court judicial and probation
Personnel employed by the city of
Lancaster Ohio for the year 2025 and to
declare an emergency administrative um
committee Mr lenberg and Mr bisj council
member bisj or excuse me council member
lenberg thank you Mr President I'd like
to make a motion Council suspend its
rules and wave the third reading of
ordinance temporarily number
second it's not marked on here excuse me
just a moment please it's not marked
star is it a star it should be a star
version okay all right it's not marked
on the agenda as a star version so we're
going to have Tove to amend the motion
we got to we got to go back to a
substitute sure if you could please uh
so I'd like to make a motion Mr
President to replace ordinance
temporarily numbered 4724 by replacing
it with uh ordinance temporarily
numbered 4724 Star as given to the clerk
in writing prior of tonight's meeting
second we have a motion in a second to
uh replace a temporary ordinance
4724 with temporary ordinance 4724 star
any discussion council member lenberg
I'd like to ask the city safety service
director to address this one yes thank
you as the mayor mentioned in the
finance committee meeting we did receive
an order from the judge um adding a
part-time special project security
officer and so we just received that
this morning so that is why you have a
star version in front of you okay thank
you any further
discussion hearing none please call the
r Mr ALS yes Mr bisj Mrs CH yes Mrs hoop
yes yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes
Miss tener no Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to replace
temporary ordinance 4724 with temporary
ordinance
4724 star passes 8 to1 council member
lenberg thank you Mr President I'd like
to make a motion to council suspend its
rules and wave the third reading of
ordinance temporarily numbered
47-24
star second we have a motion a second to
wave the third reading for temporary
ordinance 4724 star I'll just dispense
with discussion if there is none and we
can move to call the RO Mr ALS yes Mr
bisj yes Mrs PR yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes Miss tener no
Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes motion
to suspend the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary ordinance 4724 star
passes a to1 council member lenberg
thank you Mr President I'd like to make
a motion to council pass Andross and
enton the written record ordinance
temporarily number 4724 star second have
motion a second to pass gross and enter
upon the written record temporary
ordinance 4724
star no discussion please call the rooll
Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes Mrs crates yes
Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover
yes Miss tener no Mr Winger Mr Wing yes
Mr Mr wolfinger yes motion to pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
uh temporary ordinance 4724 star passes
8 to1 temporary ordinance 48- 24 star an
ordinance to establish to benefits
titles and compensation for management
and professional Personnel employed by
the city of Lancaster for Ohio for the
2025 year to and to declare an emergency
administrative committee Mr luberg and
Mr wolfinger
council member wolfing or council member
lenberg uh thank you Mr President I'd
like like to make a motion to replace
ordinance temporarily numbered
4824 uh by replacing it with ordinance
temporarily numbered 4824 Star as given
to the clerk in writing prior to
tonight's meeting second a motion second
to replace temporary ordinance 4824 with
temporary ordinance 4824 Star as given
to the clear writing before the meeting
U please or discussion uh I'd like to
ask the Ser service safety director to
address this please yes again based on
our last council meeting again the mayor
alluded to this in the finance committee
meeting uh Council had uh mentioned
wanting a facilities manager um and so
we did go ahead and add that into the
pay ordinance and that because we added
that position after the original
legislation was submitted to you you we
needed to do a star version for that as
well thank
you any further discussion hearing none
please call a roll Mr ALS yes Mr bisj
yes Mrs PR yes Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg
yes Mr skover no Miss tener no Mr Wing
yes and Mr wolfinger
yes motion to replace uh temporary
ordinance
4824 with temporary ordinance 4824 star
passes 7-2 council member lenberg thank
you Mr President I'd like to make a
motion to council suspend its rules and
wave the third reading of ordinance
temporarily number
second second we have a motion and
second to spend the rules and wave the
third reading of temporary ordinance
4824 star uh no discussion I'm assuming
please call a ro Mr ALS yes Mr bisack
yes Mrs C yes Mrs hoop yep Mr lenberg
yes Mr skover no Mr tener Miss tener no
Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes motion
to suspend the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary ordinance 4824 star
passes 7 to2 council member lenberg
thank you Mr President I'd like to make
a motion to council pass engross and
underp upon the written record ordinance
temporarily number 4824 star second have
motion second to pass Andross to enter
upon the written record temporary
ordinance 4824 star please call the rle
Mr ALS yes Mr bisack yes Mrs CR yes Mrs
hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes Mr
Miss tener no Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to pass engross and
enter upon the written record temporary
ordinance 4824 star passes 8 to
one now move to Temporary ordinance 4924
star in ordinance to established
benefits titles and compensation for
those employees who are not members of
the organ recognized bargaining unions
employed by the city of Lancaster Ohio
for the year 2025 and to declare an
emergency administrative committee Mr
lenberg and Mr
pisack council member lenberg thank you
Mr President I'd like to make a motion
replace ordinance temporarily number
4924 uh by replacing it with ordinance
temporarily number 49 24 Star as given
to the clerk in writing prior to
tonight's meeting second we have a
motion a second to replace temporary
ordinance
4924 with temporary ordinance 4924 Star
as given to the clerk in writing before
tonight's meeting council member lenberg
City Safety service director Carrie
Woody please so we actually have three
changes in this ordinance since the it
was first introduced our first uh change
is inor storm water engineering we are
removing one of the engineering
positions that has not been filled in
several years um I was not aware of that
and uh Steven wellstead brought that to
my attention so we're going to go ahead
and remove that since it's an
unnecessary
position and then we have two other
changes uh in the fire department um up
until a couple of years ago we had
always had two administrative assistants
um through attrition uh we were down to
one
and that was going that was going well
however we did have the one uh
Administrative Assistant uh just
resigned from the city and so it was the
desire of the fire chief to go ahead and
bring back not necessarily two full-time
but to make it one full-time one
part-time to help in the future so that
it's not so overwhelming for one person
so in the original uh ordinance that was
presented to you we were uh requesting a
uh an office manager position so we are
actually going to change that office
manager position and replace it with one
full-time Administrative Assistant 3
which is what it had been traditionally
and then adding a second uh part-time
Administrative Assistant
to thank
you any further discussion on the motion
to
replace hearing none please call the
roll Mr ALS yes Mr bisack yes Mrs CH yes
Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover
yes Miss tener no Mr Wing yes and Mr
wolfinger yes motion to replace
temporary ordinance 4924 with temporary
ordinance 4924 star passes 8 to one
council member lenberg thank you Mr
President I'd like to make a motion that
Council suspend its rules and wave the
third reading of ordinance temporarily
numbered 49-24 star
second we have a motion and second
suspend the rules and wave the third
reading of temporary ordinance 4924 star
please call
Mr ALS yes Mr bjack yes Mrs CH no Mrs
hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover no M
Miss tener no Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger
yes the motion to suspend the rules and
wave the third reading of temporary
ordinance
star passes
6-3 council member lenberg
uh thank you Mr President I'd like to
make a motion that Council pass and
gross and under upon the written record
ordinance temporarily numbered 4924 star
second a motion and second to pass and
gross enter upon the written record
temporary ordinance 4924
star um please caller rooll Mr ALS yes
Mr bisack yes Mrs CH yes Mr Mrs hoop yes
Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes M tener no
Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger yes motion to
pass engross and enter upon the written
record temporary ordinance 4924 star
passes
81 I have a question yes on the motion
to suspend what was the vote six to
three that doesn't meet the 75%
threshold does
it so since weor since we have one
member not um actually you know having a
seat at the moment it does it's the
number of those present at the meeting
to vote and we have he's no longer it's
75% right he resigned from Council yeah
he's not so you had six out of
nine yeah he resigned so he's not like
he's here so
666 so seven you had to have seven he's
right I apologize well okay yep thanks
for paying attention Tom thank you I
appreciate
that not used to not having the folks
here so we did not pass the motion to
suspend so um we will move back to
council member
lenberg and so that would be the second
of three readings yes thank
you we'll move to Temporary ordinance
5024 an ordinance to establish the
compensation for seasonal interns
employed by the city of Lancaster Ohio
commencing during the summer of 2025 and
to declare an emergency administrative
Comm committee um Mr lenberg and Mr
wolfinger council member lenberg uh
thank you Mr President I'd like to make
a motion to council suspend its rules
and weigh the third reading of ordinance
temporarily uh numbered
50-24 second we have a motion second to
suspend the rules and wave the uh third
reading of temporary ordinance 5024 any
discussion no sir thank you please call
the rooll Mr alss yes Mr bisack yes Mrs
CH yes Mrs
yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover no Miss
tener no Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger
yes motion to suspend the rules and wave
the third reading of temporary ordinance
5024 passes 7 to
two council member
lenberg Mr President I'd like to make a
motion that Council pass and engross and
under upon the written record ordinance
temporarily numbered 50-24
that was council member
wolfinger yeah that was second okay
thank you you didn't hear it
no so um motion to pass and gross enter
upon the written record temporary
ordinance
5024 um please call it R Mr ALS yes Mr
bisack yes Mrs CH yes Mrs hoop Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes Miss tener no
Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes motion
to pass and gross and enter upon the
written record temporary ordinance 5024
passes 8 to1 temporary ordinance 5124
star an ordinance to establish benefits
titles and compensation for the Parks
and Recreation Personnel employed by the
city of Lancaster Ohio for the year 2025
and to declare an emergency
administrative committee Mr lenberg and
Mr bjack council member lenberg thank
you Mr President I'd like to make a
motion uh to replace ordinance
temporarily number
5124 uh with Resolute or with ordinance
temporarily number 5124 Star as given to
the clerk in writing prior to tonight's
meeting second a motion is second to
replace temporary ordinance
5124 with temporary ordinance 5124 Star
as given to the clerk in writing prior
to the meeting please call the Mr ALS
yes Mr bisj yes Mrs K Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes Miss tener no
Mr Wing yes and Mr wolfinger yes motion
to replace uh temporary ordinance 5124
with temporary ordinance 5124 star
passes 8 to one council member lenberg
thank you Mr President I'd like to make
a motion that Council suspend its rules
and wave the third reading of ordinance
temporarily numbered 5124 star
second have motion second to suspend the
rules and wave the third reading of
temporary ordinance 5124 star any
discussion I'd like to call on the city
city safety director to uh discuss this
one thank you councilman leberg uh this
is the last one uh we have one change in
this ordinance and that is uh our Park
superintendent received uh notification
that the office manager for the parks
department is retiring in February so he
asked to add a
um a second office manager to train with
Carol because she's been here for many
many many years um so we added in a
second office manager and then we
included in one of the office managers
that it it will not be filled after
Carol retires in
February so it'll go back to one as soon
as Carol
retires thank you any further
discussion please call a rooll on the
motion to suspend Mr ALS yes Mr bisj yes
M sces no Mrs hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr
skover no M tener no Mr Wing yes and Mr
wol yes motion to
suspend
fails um due to um 34s vote necessary by
a vote of six to
three council member
lber um so I guess this is the second of
third readings second of three readings
on temporary ordinance 5124
star we'll now move on to First readings
of ordinances beginning with temporary
ordinance
5224 an ordinance to Grant the South
Central Power Company its successors and
assigns a franchise for the right to
acquire construct maintain and operate
in the streets there therefore
as their Affairs Al Bridges and public
places of the city of Lancaster Ohio and
its successors lines for the
transmission and distribution of
electric energy to the city of Lancaster
and the inhabitants
thereof for light heat power and other
purposes and for the transmission of the
same within through or across said city
of Lancaster and to declare an emergency
this is a law committee Mrs kit and Mr
wolfinger councilman cres first of two
readings first of two readings on
temporary ordinance
5224 temporary ordinance
5324 an ordinance to deed two Parcels of
city property
58610 0 and
030000 containing
3.9 plus or minus acres of land from the
city of the of the city to be cons
Consolidated into one parcel law
committee
um U Mrs Kites and Mr bisj council
member K yes thank you Mr President as
discussed during finance committee um
the city owns two pieces of property out
on East Main Street um one next to the
fire department they want to combine the
parcels so that the fire department can
build a maintenance and Supply building
or maintenance and repair facility
behind um and this is to allow the mayor
to execute the document to get that done
so would you like to move to suspend I'm
sorry I would like to move to suspend
sorry Mr President I would like to make
a motion that Council suspend its rules
and wave the second and third readings
of res of ordinance temporarily numbered
52-24 53
53-24 second second we have a motion and
second to suspend the rules and move the
second and third reading of temporary
ordinance
5324 uh we've had a bit of discussion on
it
uh please call the rooll Mr ALS yes Mr
bisj yes Mrs KES yes Mrs hoop yes Mr
lenberg yes Mr skover yes Miss tener yes
Mr Wing yes Mr wolfinger yes temporary
uh the motion to suspend the rules in
way of the second third reading of
temporary ordinance 5324 passes 9 to Z
council member K yes let's try this
again uh Mr President I would like to
make a motion that Council pass and
gross and enter upon the written record
ordinance temporarily number 53 -24
second we have motion a second to pass
gross and enter upon the written record
temporary ordinance
5324 any further
discussion hearing none please call a ro
Mr ALS yes Mr bisack yes Mrs CH yes Mrs
hoop yes Mr lenberg yes Mr skover yes
Miss tener no oh no yes
I she was she was in a
mode this is the combining the two parts
yeah yes I know yeah Mr roll
sorry yes Mr wolfinger
yes all right temporary the motion pass
and gross enter upon the written record
temporary ordinance
5324 passes 9 to zero with a little bit
of effort on our parts um tabled
legislation I think we heard earlier in
finance the temporary resolution uh
11024 star is still on the table
um and we won't be taking that off this
evening unless there's a
motion so we're done with that we'll
move
now the walkin piece we have a Walkin oh
we do have the walkin piece I'm sorry
5424 sorry about that folks it's a it's
at night so um you're to want to read
absolutely we do have one walk-in piece
of legislation this evening in
ordin an ordinance authoriz the service
safety director to enter into a lease
contract with the fairfi County
Commissioners for the second floor of
the City Annex Building one23 East
Chestnut Street for juvenile court
services that's temporary ordinance
54 24 and the sponsor would be um
administrative committee and Mr lenberg
and Mr wolfinger council member
lenberg I think it's first of three
first of three readings first of two
reading first of two readings two
readings and I you I don't need to
Second this okay so and okay first of
two readings on temporary ordinance 5424
and with that I think we've concluded
our uh legislation this evening and
we've gone through the tabled
legislation um any Unfinished Business
by any council member Mr President
council member Wing uh I want to take
some time uh to digest mayor McDaniel's
comments about the uh water situation
over the weekend and want to be sure to
uh thank the mayor service safety
director and all the employees of the
water department who have been working
uh 247 to address the situation um for
those council members who are at
Friday's committee meeting uh you could
clearly see the weight of the situation
on the superintendent's shoulders so uh
very serious and thank you for all your
efforts with that and uh just wanted to
also publicly sayate that I
support and like to be of assistance of
and uh helping get uh sorry train
thought again uh emergency
communications out I think that's
something we need to work on and I'm
happy to help with that thank you any
further uh um unfinished business from
Council Members at this
time seeing none we'll move to new
business there was on my agenda
appointment of a council person to serve
on the tree commission but the lucky
take for that was last meeting and
council member ALS uh did fill that
position so we thank him for that we'll
move to the announcements of scheduled
meting Mr President yes council member
SC just in terms of new business to
address
the Mr Everett and Mr baros in terms of
The Pedestrian safety I mean I think Mr
Everett's going to come every meeting to
to mention it which is which is fine
it's a nice reminder uh it's definitely
a long-term plan that we have to look at
I think in the short term and chief
Snider's not here but the directed
Patrol unit for
LPD
um you always hear great things about it
it's something new it's something that's
I think a little more complaint
driven um for them to focus on certain
things in the community if I am wrong in
that let me know but I think the biggest
issue is you see those complaints and I
see them on Facebook more often than not
and the question I have is are we
calling
LPD and saying Hey There is the speeding
in the neighborhood there is this in the
neighborhood or we just posting it on
Facebook and as everybody has seen some
of us troll Facebook a little more than
others and you
know everybody is like hey this boil
alert notice on Facebook wasn't
sufficient enough but Facebook Facebook
sufficient enough to complain
about those things but are we actually
calling the right department so I'd be
interested to see if you know we have
the reduced
speed Mobile sign that we move around
directed Patrol unit could do the same
thing if they're getting those
complaints and realistically it's like
we see plenty of complaints there are
plenty of people that don't know how to
drive don't know how to obey basic
traffic laws
um I'm going to mention Mr Everett again
because I was up and happened to
be picking up my grandkids from a
traffic accident at the intersection in
front of your house the other night and
I was there before LPD so I controlled
the the intersection cuz people there's
a T-bone accident people were still
wanting just to flow in and out of that
and and you know the girl that I mean
she had stopped she assumed it was a
four-way stop and then she just came out
and T-Bone
and she was upset but at the same time
we're talking about maybe it's a simple
we at least start with they're already
on the payroll do we use directed Patrol
unit to start cracking down on basic
moving violations and whether that's
worth their time or not you know it's
it's something I'd like to hear from at
some point but at and the mayor knows so
I I think that's a way to start what
what you're asking for in terms of a
long-term plan for pedestrians right so
just food for that thank you council
member skover um yes Mr Mayor I just
want to reply to that I think you're
right the director Patrol unit was
created specifically to
address uh not just traffic problems but
problems throughout the city um I think
we also have some other projects in the
pipeline that people know about
pedestrian safety projects as far as
additional sidewalk uh stud we are
currently studying pedestrian Crossings
on uh Memorial Drive to get people
across as Mr Evert mentioned uh
sometimes that means getting them
halfway across on one light cycle and
the rest of way across on the second
light cycle but we need to have
protected areas for them to be at so we
have a study that we that we've paid for
that council's approved currently in the
works on pedestrian safety on Memorial
Drive but that's just the tip of the
iceberg I I think probably in the last
week I know of at least four pedestrian
crashes um I don't think there was
significant injury on any of them but
could have been could have been
significant we pedestrians as well as
Motor Vehicles aren't always paying
attention but a pedestrian a crosswalk
isn't being yielded to and that's
something PD could enforce um and we'll
speak with the chief about that he'll be
totally on board but that's
not the ultimate way to solve this
problem I think um there's a lot of
things we can do better some of the
things we have in progress sidewalks on
East Main Street uh sidewalks we build
on South Broad those are all helpful
steps in the right direction but uh we
need to study the pro problem look at it
uh it's going to cost money to address
some of it but we can definitely make an
impact on pedestrian safety bicyclist
safety wheelchair uh accessible safety
uh and we can also do things I think
with signage to draw better
attention uh to the areas you know I I
me uh Ray uh crosswalks were mentioned
that is a doal purpose R it draws
attention to crosswalk but it also
serves as a speed bump and I know we're
resistant to speed bumps speed humps etc
etc there's a good reason for that but
it doesn't mean in our heavily
pedestrian areas they shouldn't be
considered so uh we'll speak with the
chief and feel free anyone of you would
like to speak with Chief Snyder about a
problem area including pedestrian safety
feel free to reach out to him but we'll
reach out to him on your behalf also
thank you Mr Mayor I know service safety
director sorry excuse me uh service
safety director Woody had indicated that
we we didn't have the special
presentation tonight but it was supposed
to be L do is that correct so maybe the
next time they come in they could also
give us some updates about some of those
issues as well as council member I've
had a few uh instances in my ward where
I've asked the directed Patrol units to
be involved and they have and and
successfully I mean they're and and then
they come back I I walked out my front
door and there's a policeman sitting in
front of my house and you know I asked
him what he was doing he said well you
had this complaint about two months ago
and we're just here to make sure that
we follow up and so they they do they're
involved and and and it works and and I
have to tell you a funny story and one
of the places was at the corner of Fair
Avenue and maple Madison running stop
signs my my wife got stopped after I
complained about
people my wife was one of the the 80
some people that got stopped at the stop
s sign she's going to kill me cuz she's
watching but I Don't
Care Council memb SC just just as a
followup to clarify I when we were
sitting here having the meeting that's
when director Pro Patrol you I know how
they that they are helpful with that but
I think the biggest part of my comment
is you can't and not not saying anyone
specifically here but you can't just
complain about it on on Facebook and
expect LPD to notice it and we in plenty
of these meetings and there's a lot of
projects and the works but as far as
like something that can happen tomorrow
it's start making those phone calls to
the right people and those things can
start improving as we work to those
bigger projects you can actually go
online you don't even have to if you can
go right online and and file the
Complaint Form yeah council member tener
yeah I I mean I have not I think that
they do do a good job with uh the speed
limit I've seen the big things out
they'll make sure you're you're timed
and I know they were on Van Buren and uh
what is that I can't think what the name
of it is rumfield over by glasow Park
and they were sitting there and I didn't
know if they were looking for something
Park here they were parked back and they
got I I don't know if there was 60 some
or 80 some people speeding and I guess
it was 25 I had no idea I live there 20
some years didn't know it was 25 miles
hour but also never got caught I was
smarter
well thank you for that uh
self-disclosure we appreciate that okay
if there's no other uh comments we I'm
I'm very happy we were able to provide
that feedback and um and um we'll now
move to the regularly scheduled uh City
Council meetings um we have December 9th
at 6:30 p.m. council chambers um January
13th at 6:30 p.m that's 2025 at 6:30
p.m. Council Chambers thank you special
meetings we have none scheduled
regularly scheduled uh committee
meetings service committee service
committee meeting December 6 at 8:00
a.m. City Hall 1897 conference room
Public Public Works December committee I
can't talk now December 13th um was
cancelled at
7:30 um administrative service committee
December 18th at 8:00 a.m. City Hall 8
1997 conference room thank you reading
of bills mnco
$177 43 and Amazon for
$33.90 paid on a PNC card Mr President
i' like to make a motion to pay the
bills second have a motion a second to
pay the bills all those in favor please
signify by saying I I I all those post
same sign bills are paid executive
session we have no need um we're going
to move for an adjournment but before we
do uh what folks in the audience saw
tonight was a lot of work by a lot of
people to keep this meeting going you
know we had a lot of uh different things
happening this evening but what you saw
was cooperation from everybody in this
room and uh we value that here at the
city of Lancaster and um we appreciate
the community coming to give us feedback
as well uh so thank you I'll take an
emotion to adjourn Mr President I'd like
to make that motion we adjourn second we
have a motion a second to adjourn all
those in favor please signify by saying
I I thank you please sign your
legislation before you leave this
evening I may need a place to sleep
tonight
[Music]
e